foreign
Knoxville Tennessee what's up Renee
hi what's up
nothing much how are you pretty good
pretty good what's happening how can I
help
um
I'm having a problem
um my husband he's Henry happy he's an
alcoholic I'm so happy he's in rehab
but I have times where I am just so
depressed
not because he's in I'm I love that he's
in rehab and I love that he is trying
I'm so proud of him but I get into where
I'm just I don't know what to do to get
out of the depression can I ask you a
hard question
yes
yes are you mad at him too
with what we
are you mad at him too
let me say this it's a trick question I
know you are just say it out loud
yeah yeah
are you frustrated and sad
yes are you broken-hearted
yes did you have this awesome picture of
the way your life was going to be at
your age and it looks nothing like it
and you're sitting alone while your
husband's in rehab
yes
all of those things get pushed lower and
lower and lower
some would call them getting compressed
another word for compress is to depress
and if you're not honest about what your
body is feeling
your body will hide it but it will
they'll still be there and they will
Poison every part of your spirit and
every part of your life
you got to be honest about him
about what we went through
and before I did that I went through
some soul searching myself while he's in
rehab and I felt like I was doing good
I was like okay I've gotten through this
and then they told me to write the
letter
and since then it's been like
I'm constantly thinking about everything
we went through again that's right
and let me tell you this the alcoholism
is a context not an excuse
yes he shouldn't have cheated on you he
shouldn't he cussed at you he shouldn't
have swung at you and I'm just making
things up he may have done none of those
things
but all those things that happen should
not have happened they were still abused
they were still wrong they were still
painful and still hurtful
and it can be both and
you can be enraged at a man you love
Trilogy like that and you can be
heartbroken that he's sick
and you can be disgusted and thinking
about not wanting to be married to him
anymore and be really at peace that he's
in rehab
the depression the exhaustion you feel
that existent like the I don't you wanna
I don't want to eat I don't want to get
up
it's your body trying to force you to
live in one of those extremes without
accepting the tension that is
and you're trying to think your way into
peace and you can't you got to act
that's why with them asking you to do
something like write a letter was so
good and I would ask you to write
another one and another one after that
because it's gonna it's like
man when you pull that bandage off and
rip the scab off that sucker is infected
and it's going to bleed and bleed and
bleed and you gotta let it go
but that's scary for you why is that
scary
because I've always been the one who had
to
keep control of my emotions
because even when my parents passed away
I I had to keep the smile on my face and
for my kids no you didn't no you didn't
you chose to that was a choice
it's just the way I felt because if I
thought if they saw me upset then it was
upset for you so that's right and you
know I'm not trying to shame you the
greatest gift you could give your kids
is to show them that you're upset
it's the greatest gift you can give your
children
other than a great marriage and here's
why because when your parents died they
got really really sad
yes and they looked at mom who was still
smiling and they go on to think they're
crazy
but when Mom says I'm so sad I'm crying
my eyes out by myself we all come sit
with me because I miss my mommy I miss
my dad
it makes your kids feel not nuts
it makes them feel whole
see what I'm saying
if your husband's off at rehab and
you're just being a good old southern
Knoxville mama and you are cleaning
things up and making sure everything's
not Dusty
they're gonna think that their parent
isn't is a animatron is a robot
and they're gonna feel insane and in
many ways you feel that way too don't
you
yes
because I can be happy one minute and
then the next I'm just wanting to fall
apart and scream and in counseling we
call it leakage and I know it's a
terrible way to say it you can deal with
those emotions or they will deal with
you and they usually will deal with you
at a real inopportune time when your
margin is the thinnest when you're about
to give a big presentation at work when
you're about to have a hard conversation
with your kids when you get pulled over
when you when one parent looks at you
wrong and you're just like listen here
mother you just go off right
they will come out
and so I think it's much more wiser to
deal with it on my own on my terms in my
safe space with my counselor with my
notebook with my journal whatever that
is with my gym I don't whatever it is I
gotta deal with it because it will deal
with me
no but you are doing your damn well best
to make yourself crazy
you're working hard at it yeah you're
doing good at it
you really are trying hard because I'm
trying because I'm
and that's beautiful but that's also
that's your drug that's a defense
mechanism for you
that's performative it's playing
what the world really needs is Renee to
be Renee
what you need is a healthy dose of
honesty
or let me say it this way this is a rude
way to say it but I'm just going to be
honest with you
you're every bit the addict your husband
is
yes I agree with that I'm not an addict
but I'm I you're an addict he's an
addict to alcohol you're an addict too
control
you're an addict to Performance you're
an attitude making sure everybody else
is at peace and even I'll die on that
altar but as long as everybody there's
no one can see a ripple in the water and
the sheets are straight at the edge of
this bed we're all good
okay is that fair
yeah yeah
I won't expect anything I'll do whatever
whatever I know but you sacrifice your
happiness to try to make other people
happy and they feel they know that
you're not happy and that makes that
keeps them from ever having Joy
the greatest gift you can give somebody
else is
you
foreign
is you've probably been peacekeeping for
a long long time is that fair
yes I can so you're going to go through
a season of practicing
of saying what you actually think
and then when that guilt wave comes over
you like a tsunami you gotta just sit
take it
someone's gonna ask you hey could you
make all the pies like you did last year
for the thing and you're gonna say
you're not even gonna give an excuse
you're going to say no
um not this year thank you so much for
the invitation
and that's it that's all you're going to
say
you don't owe them any like well I just
can't because I've well I've got you
know anybody an explanation
you can just say no and then when you do
that your body will feel like shame and
loser and I'm the worst in it and you're
gonna have to just for the first time
feel it
and probably have somebody with you
feeling it
writing it down
because it's going to all be new
it's going to all be new
but when it comes to
feeling those feelings the next logical
step when you actually feel them becomes
boundaries
you will not drink in my home
you will not talk to me or my kids this
way
you will not take our money and spend it
you will not sleep with other people
when we're married like or whatever your
boundaries happen to be and for your
particular situation with your husband
but here's the thing it's completely
normal to feel chaos and feelings and I
feel this but I also feel this I can't
be around this person but I still love
them I love this person but they're not
the right person for me to marry I'm so
grateful this person's in rehab and I'm
so ticked off that they screwed up
everything
that's adulthood it's being able to
handle the tension
but I want to put your husband's
Addiction on the side and I want you to
get in touch with Renee for the first
time in your whole life
what you feel what you think and scary
and frighteningly what do you actually
want you get one shot at this little
crazy life we got what do you want
what do you want
because whatever it is you you you can
go get it
you can go get it